welcome back to my retrospective review
of wood of dragonballs ugly stepchildren
Dragon Ball GT in this third part I will
be dissecting and reviewing the beloved
super Android 17 saga a story about how
to android 17s linked hell and
themselves together in order to create
the most powerful foe the series has yet
seen and it's really not good so prepare
for that but before I get into the new
stuff this week I wanted to touch on
something I didn't last week
Piccolo's death while I can appreciate
his reasoning for wanting to off himself
sort of I mean I'm still not sure how
the balls or why the balls are linked to
him after he fused the comi anyway I
would have liked if he had played a
bigger role in that arc 23 episodes and
he featured woods briefly only to show
up at the end in a dramatic emotional
send-off of sorts that really landed
flat trimming it didn't feel like
something that was part of the story but
more like something that was tagged on
at the end just because that moment was
leaning exclusively on Dragon Ball Z to
carry the emotional resonance for that
seemed to work and I think it deserves
more however today I am not here to talk
about the baby saga this week I am
tackling the super Android 17 saga
episodes 41 to 47 let's do this world
championship I'm excited I always love a
good Dragon Ball tournament but this is
actually filler it has nothing to do
with the story that follows so I'll
glaze over it as quickly as I can
Goku is fighting in the kids division
because mr. Satan is feeling depressed
after what happened to Buu in the last
arc and so he wishes for pan to take his
place by winning the tournament but I
spoke too soon as mr. Stayton is being
given a massage one of the tournament
officials explains that the four
finalists have been determined and pan
has elected to withdraw from the
competition as she has no interest in
being the successor to mr. Satan we
switch over to Goku as the children's
division finals get underway he's facing
some unassuming kid called Maggie or
Magoo day however before he gets a
chance to begin Vegeta barges in like a
WWE wrestler demanding a fight with Goku
while Goku is distracted Miggy or pushes
Goku out and wins thrilling stuff
following that epic display the adult
divisions Championship match begins epic
irreversible and the fight begins and
I mean papaya man gives ever cheery a
German suplex after which he immediately
gives up the pie man is the victor and
Goku tells him to remove his mask it xub
yeah because panet pulled out mr. Satan
now has to face off against boob who
takes the fight pretty seriously and
starts thrashing on mr. Satan right as
he's about to deal the finishing blow to
mr. Satan Buu stops
right in his tracks I kind of love that
it totally caught me off guard and who
believes himself wide open for mr. Satan
to land one punch knock him out of
bounds Satan gets emotional believing
that he won using his own abilities
against ooh that's a really sweet
parting gift majin buu left for his
grieving friend this win gives mr. Satan
new life and vigor encouraging him to
remain the world's champion all in all
this episode was pretty cute nice
self-contained story that wraps
everything up in a wholesome boat at the
end but now it's time for the main
entree episode two dr. mu is still alive
I have several quite know he finds
himself walking aimlessly in Hell when
he runs into dr. Jerome they decide to
join forces in their efforts to bring an
end to son Goku I have no idea how
they're gonna achieve this from hell but
I'm sure we're gonna find out Hyde
plucked a Goku's house as his friends
and family are having a get-together
over dinner and knock on the door
reveals an injured trunks on the verge
of collapse before fainting he utters
Android 17 investigating the situation
they notice a massive hole in the clouds
outside as they observe this Kim Chi
begins ringing Goku's ear informing him
back for some reason the living world
and other world had become stuck
together we later learned that this is
due to an android 17 in hell linking
with android 17 in the living world from
the outset it looks as though Android 17
in the living world is being controlled
in some capacity either by the other
Android or Jareau in hell that much is
honestly still not understood and I hope
you don't miss King Kai because that's
literally the last time we see him in
this arc once this is all explained
seventeen challenges Goku to come to
hell alone because that would be the
smart thing to do in order to fight the
people he sent there know this aren't
frames it's such that Goku is
responsible for all the villains being
placed in health
what follows is the release from Hell
and pouring out onto earth of all the
villains a news broadcast proceeds to
show images of escaping villains the
vast majority of which Vegeta ended the
lives of and not Goku and just as a
quick aside when it comes to E
major villains like Frieza and self he
might have defeated Frieza but Future
Trunks sent him to other world and Sal
was defeated by go on regardless of all
this goku accepts the challenge blindly
charging into the void alone and while
this is all happening the forces of
earth defend it from the villains that
have been released
naturally when goku goes up to hell to
confront seventeen dr. gyro and dr. mu
they give him the slip and proceed to
earth without him trapping goku in hell
who could have seen that coming but
that's not all the episode comes to a
close and it's revealed that Frieza and
cells remained in hell to face off
against Goku episode 3 kicks off as Goku
begins going toe-to-toe with Frieza and
Sal not being intimidated in the
slightest and exploding while powering
up it's not really a fight or even taken
seriously by Goku who literally surfs on
a Kansan thrown by Frieza needless to
say in a quick and embarrassing fashion
Goku begins dismantling the two warriors
however one small hiccup they are
immortal in hell I'll address that later
smash cut again to earth as we see
Vegeta confronted by nappa this I
thought was a perfect time for some
dialogue between the two Saiyans
giving Vegeta a chance to express all
the changes he's undergone since their
last parting but nope he's gone in
literally an instant but fret not
seventeen is here to take his place
instead we then cut back to the fight in
hell as cell a successfully absorbs Goku
but Goku somehow crawls back out since
that wasn't successful Frieza and cell
using a new technique send him to house
basement or something a place beneath
the current hell they dwell within
underneath the clouds at this point I
honestly have no idea what's going on
once in this strange place Goku becomes
part of a stew prepared by this old
woman but that's not all unfortunately
in this strange place she places Goku in
a number of strange and uncomfortable
scenarios I don't know what her goal is
here exactly
and her preventing him from moving I
don't even know is necessary can Goku
even get out of here is it possible to
do so under his own power I have
honestly no idea because of this a lack
of information the tension that I assume
they are trying to achieve doesn't exist
or have the chance to exist as I have no
idea what the parameters of this realm
even are what's possible here we cut to
earth as Android 17 encounters Android
18 managing to put our
under some sort of mind control my
assumption is the same mind control at
17 is currently under himself the fourth
episode kicks off in a major way
Krillin attempts to reach 18 and 17 as
all of this is going on expressing his
confusion as to why 17 is working for
Jerome that he once resented him why is
he working for him he expresses it seems
to work for a moment but quickly 17
snaps back under this evil influence
firing a blast straight through Crillon
leaving his body lifeless in the arms of
his wife Android 18 and man does she
lose it absolutely savaging and
brutalizing her brother for what he's
done screaming to give Crillon back it's
honestly really powerful raw stuff and
one of if not the most powerful scenes
I've ever seen from Android 18 since her
introduction to the show seventy no ever
is much more powerful than her
unfortunately easily leaving her in a
heap next to her husband before making
his way to his doppelganger back in Hell
Frieza and Sal discover goku after being
frozen in ice by the old woman taking
advantage of this they charged their
final blast to destroy the Saiyan
however in the nick of time Goku manages
to break free from the ice the ice can
only keep those who are already dead
frozen apparently and so he turns the
tables on them using that very same ice
trap we switched back to earth as the
Android 17 from hell is evenly matched
against Vegeta who for some reason
doesn't go super saiyan but not for long
the other 17 arrives and quickly begins
to change things they fuse I don't like
this idea personally this story didn't
really convince or selling on a fan of
the design personally but let's see how
things pan out we all begin rushing
super Android 17 because that's the
smart thing to do in this situation
resulting in pretty much how you
imagined it going down everyone getting
debt and while this is all happening
Goku is trying to figure out a way to
get out of hell apparently Emma can't do
it as something outside of his control
or our knowledge is preventing it as
this is said it shows the Dragon Balls
cracking I have no idea what this means
it
piccolo during this interrupts this line
of thought somehow requesting to be
placed in hell
so Yama can put piccolo in Hell but not
take Goku out seems convenient
anyways piccolo has a plan episode 5
okay so Piccolo's plan is to connect the
earth with the world the same way the
two 17s did at the begin
using his connection with denday okay
first of all he can communicate with
then day beyond the grave okay fine I
mean I thought you needed someone like
Kim Chi to do that but whatever what I
want to know is why did piccolo need to
be brought to Hell in the first place
couldn't even a dystopia and told him to
make a connection with him and one of
his sons earlier surely they are more
similar than piccolo and NDR and piccolo
ends up not even being able to do it
until Goku helps them anyway
whatever once the Gateway is open Goku
uses this as an opportunity to leave and
join the battle on earth against super
Android 17 however before he arrives
Vegeta is on the verge of being sent to
Otherworld himself
that is until pan takes things into her
own hands holding dr. Gero hostage with
guilt the real MVP she demands that
super Android 17 stop in his tracks and
he does he stops a me at Vegeta and
switches to dr. o and pan this swerve is
insanely bad dr. mu begins laughing
facing the other doctor practically
twirling his moustache explained that
while they were developing the Android
another world off-screen might I add he
enhanced him such that he would only
listen to his commands and needless to
say this results in Jarosz demise Vegeta
quickly regains his footing and begins
blustering about how he doesn't need
Kakarot how he's the real number one etc
only two seconds later be saved by
Kakarot bringing the episode to a close
we are now entering the final two
episodes and so begins the battle
between super Android 17 and Goku Goku
punches the Android once and sends him
literally to the other side of the
planet Android 17 proceeds to express
how KooKoo is letting him down very
cliche at this point I'm just waiting
for Super Saiyan 4 yet Goku persists and
only using the regular Super Saiyan form
also as another quick aside the sheer
number of times Android 17 in this arc
has pushed back his hair in the exact
same way is more than the number of
scenes piccolo has had in this entire
series so far just saying
anyways Goku gets right up into his face
and fires a point-blank kamehameha to
zero effect and so finally Super Saiyan
4 comes out and we can start taking
things seriously we then smash cut to
possibly the last thing I expected a
short scene with chichi Bulma Vidal and
brah as they make plans to join the
action - I have no idea what's happening
anymore anyways the Android is absorbing
Goku's blasts and so naturally because
this is how the fight is written
begins firing an enormous and
unreasonable number of random key blasts
that are completely out of character for
him also super Android 17 has this
ability to absorb energy despite both
Android 17 specifically not having that
ability at all and even if I were to
ignore that the fight is so boring
because the Android can absorb his ki
attacks when goku learns this he acts as
if his hands are tied
goku is not just a ki attack guy the
entire fight with Frieza on Namek while
it did have ki attacks incorporated the
vast majority was martial arts hand to
hand close quarters combat and another
thing to confirm that the Android was
absorbing the attacks
Goku fires his strongest blast at him so
one of two things would happen in this
instance either his assumption that he
does in fact absorb his energy would be
proven correct and he does absorb that
energy or he blow up the earth because
he's aiming downwards episode 7 the
final episode kicks things off as the
girls are making their way to the action
for some reason goku manages to dodge
the androids big attack and teleports
behind him using all of his limbs to
restrain him in this moment goku begins
to gather power and releases a giant
burst of energy as a dust clears goku is
in his infant bass form once again and
the Android is still alive apparently he
raised his barrier or something super
Android 17 begins charging the same
blast he did earlier to finish off Goku
went out of nowhere Android 18 appears
on the battlefield
she begins reprimanding him for sending
crew into all the world and Goku hears
this news she apparently survived the
last attack at the hands of her brother
because he was purposely avoiding her
vital area that once housed a bomb
placed there by the late dr. Jerome
however it has unbeknownst to Android 17
been removed by the dragon and so
Android 18 begins to bluff while this is
all going on dr. mew begins calling 17
pathetic and a coward for not firing on
goku and 18 anyway resulting in your
guest at dr. mew being blown up instead
at the hands of 1718 uses this moment of
distraction as an opportunity to unload
a bombardment of key attacks on the
super Android resulting in him absorbing
all of the energy she releases Goku
notices that when he absorbs the energy
he needs to have his body in a
particular pose what a strange design
choice leaving himself white of a fur
attack and Goku does just that flying
right through him with a dragon fist and
landing consecutive Kamehameha's
finishing the fight
not a fad the episode wraps up as they
conclude that 17 must have known about
the bomb and still missed intentionally
because she was his sister
the girls arrived but are too late and
they take care of any and all loose ends
with the dragonballs ho boy where do I
begin
okay Dragon Ball GT s first arc was
mindless adventure babies Ark was
fighting mixed with adventure each facet
fighting and adventure serving a purpose
in telling the story of the baby Ark in
this super Android 17 arc it's the
opposite of the first instead of
mindless adventure it's just mindless
fighting the arc is almost exclusively
fighting and the fights have no weight
behind them all of these villains have
been defeated get no dialogue and are
simply there to facilitate numbers to
prevent and give trouble to Earth's
forces which we barely see
additionally where the last arc with
baby succeeded the arc being just about
him this arc is not really about Android
17 consistently shifting focus from him
to various other villains that
ultimately have little or nothing to do
with the main story and its climax in
other words it doesn't build up to
anything at its core this is a revenge
story sort of the two doctors getting
their revenge on Goku yet the two
doctors are eliminated by seventeen who
has no known motivation to us in the
story what does he want if he wants what
dr. Mew wants then why did he remove him
entirely I really didn't like this
aspect of the story and it only further
emphasised that the people in charge of
this only wanted to create excuses for
them to fight and had nothing to say
well little to nothing to say the scenes
including Android 18 and krillen who
were honestly very touching and hit all
the right notes for me personally the
arc was at its best when she and her
husband were on-screen amazing I think
how they played such a small role while
being so important to the story it's a
bit of a waste in all honesty speaking
of waste the stuff that happens to Goku
in Hell isn't compelling it's all rather
silly and takes up too much time within
this already very short story it keeps
introducing new aspects of the hell
landscape that weren't privy to us prior
therefore they don't act as surprises
just conveniences to keep Goku locked
down in there like him and not being
able to pull him out of there or there
being a basement to hell at all or Goku
being able to melt just because he's
alive stuff like that and all of these
new reveals don't really add anything to
the story
just facilitate ways to delay it for
Goku to proceed and foresail and Frieza
to finally meet their defeat in hell
speaking of Frieza and cell why is it
that they are immortal in hell this
makes no sense to me during the end of
Dragon Ball Z in the final fight against
Kid Buu wasn't it stated to Vegeta that
if he loses here while in the afterlife
he won't be able to come back that he'll
stop existing or something additionally
the entire arc hinges on this
brainwashing of the androids angle and
yet it's never explained how this is
even possible or even how dr. gyro and
dr. mu found the supplies or parts
necessary to create Android 17 in hell
it's just glazed over as if it's some
unimportant detail yet the entire story
is built upon it my final criticism for
this arc is that the fights were
honestly really boring
perhaps this was because they had no
emotional weight for me but I genuinely
wasn't impressed by the action even on a
surface level
everything looks standard and Blair and
those are my thoughts on Dragon Ball GT
super Android 17 saga Blair a saga that
felt about as good as a rush book report
and felt slower and more monotonous than
the vast majority of sagas despite it
only really being six episodes long if
you don't include the filler episode at
the beginning
currently GT is batting one for three so
far so not exactly a fantastic record
but who knows maybe you can come away
with a good result next week with its
final arc this shadow Dragon's saga but
that'll do it for this week don't forget
to leave a like and subscribe if you
want to see more videos like this thank
you so much for watching oh my god you
don't blow your tits
sis that's wack you gotta kill yourself
before you kill yourself this can't
actually be real
[Music]